I've always been kind of
a doodler and a drawer.
Two years ago when I
was working at an agency
in the city, I made my
CEO a pair of sneakers.
It kind of grew from there.
I always was this female
thinker and creator
in this male space that I said to myself,
why can't the two be together?
Being connected on Instagram and online
has enhanced my work, my visibility,
and it's enhanced my
ability to collaborate.
The questionnaire really
simplifies the way that I design.
It's essentially things I
would naturally ask a friend
of mine if I were
designing their sneakers.
When I start drawing
on a sneaker, I like to
incorporate the curves
into my work rather than
trying to fit in a certain
design within a certain space.
What I love about art, and about
the sneaker world in general,
is that it's colorful,
it's energetic, it has to do with sport,
but it also has to do with aesthetics.
But I think that people
really remember my work
because they see this unique hybrid,
and it resonates with a lot of people.
Taking small steps toward your
goals can have a huge impact.
Taking little steps to
where you want to go
is way better than not trying at all.